Hey there.
I'm Addy Osmani.
I'm a Developer Programs
Engineer on the
Chrome team at Google.
And today we're going to talk
about some new Chrome DevTools
features spanning work
spaces, snippets,
and an improved Sass.
Debugging workflow.
Now, these features are going to
hopefully help improve your
authoring and productivity
in the tools, so
let's dive right in.
A typical web app development
workflow usually involves a
clever window arrangement of
having your editor and the
browser with your dev tools
living side by side, and
constantly making this sort of
cumbersome context switch
between these tools.
Now, rather than having to do
that, wouldn't it be great if
you could spend a little bit
more of that time that you're
editing files on directly inside
the dev tools, so that
you could both debug and edit
your project files?
Now I'm going to talk about
Workspaces, which is a new
feature we've been able to
facilitate this workflow.
So, I currently have an
application open that's sort
of a page level right now.
And what I want to do is
actually be able to go and
open up and edit my entire
project, so everything that
makes up this project on
my local file system.
And the way I'm going to do that
is I'm going to go and
I'm going to add this
application--
HTML5 Please--
locally.
You should now be able to see
that I have two sets of
directories.
I have my page level view of
this page, and then my entire
project level view.
And I want to be able to
consolidate these, so whenever
I make a change, they apply to
both what Chrome is able to
display and what I'm able to
experience during debugging,
and the changes I'm making to
my original source files.
So I'm going to go and I'm going
to right click on any
file, really, inside
my project.
I'm going to go and I'm
going to map them
to file system resource.
And I'm just going to choose
the option which basically
maps it back to the original
source file.
Chrome DevTools is going
to ask me to restart.
It's gone and it's done that.
And now you see I just
have one single view.
This one view consolidates
everything, and it basically
represents my entire project,
and all the files that make up
my whole application.
And I can go and I can edit.
I can edit my index file.
I can edit any of
my build files.
I can go and I can edit
my JavaScript.
And the first thing I want to do
is I want to make sure that
in this new workspace world,
I'm still able to do things
like live edit and life debug,
and use my breakpoints.
So let's do that.
I want to locate a specific
method called updatesearch.
And I'm going to do that using
a keyboard shortcut called
Command-Shift-O. And it's called
updatesearch, so I've
typed that in.
It's is gone and it's
taken me there.
And what I'm now going to do
is I want to change this
application so that--
so the current way this works
is I type in a tag.
So it can be video,
audio, canvas, or
another HTML5 feature.
And this page will basically let
me know whether it's safe
or not to use that feature.
What I want is, whenever I type
into the search field, I
basically want it to
log to the console.
So I'm going to add a little
console log statement here.
I'm going to say,
console.log("We're
updating!").
And I'm going to do Command
Save, just to save that back.
And using the Escape shortcut
key, I'm going to open up a
local console which can be
displayed at the same time as
the Sources panel, so
I can see my output.
What I now want to see is
whatever I type in something,
as you can see, that's logging
correctly to the console,
which is great.
So I know that live editing
seems to be working fine.
The next thing I want to be
able to do is work with
breakpoints.
So we can still use updatesearch
for this.
Let me add a breakpoint to
classList, and I can do this
by clicking inside the
line number gutter.
And I can do that inside a few
other places in my code.
And what I'm now going to do is
basically go back to here
and start typing it again.
And the first thing you'll
notice is that it's triggered
that first breakpoint.
And I can go and I can continue
on to the next
breakpoint just by right
clicking inside the gutter,
and clicking on the next one
and going to continue here,
which will continue execution
up to that point.
And I can continue to the
next one right after
that if I want to.
So let's kill the stuff
that we had in console
there at the moment.
Now, something that I noticed
with workspace that's actually
pretty cool is the ability
for DevTools--
let me show you this.
I'm going to come to close
my script file.
I'm going to close
the DevTools.
So let's assume that we've
restarted Chrome.
I'm going to open up my Sources
panel once again.
And I'm going to go back to
script.js, which is what we
were working on.
And what you'll now see is that
all those breakpoints
that I created are actually
still there.
The DevTools have been able
to remember them.
And it can do that for
any number of files.
I can have a bunch of different
scripts that are
composing my application, and
it'll basically remember the
different breakpoint
settings for them.
I can actually go and--
I can still add things
like conditional
breakpoints as well.
So here, what I want to do
is say, if the value of
search.value is panda, for
example, I basically want it
to trigger this breakpoint.
So I can type in audio
and nothing happens.
But I type in panda, and it's
triggered that conditional
breakpoint.
I can actually-- so let's
continue working through
there, and let's get rid of that
conditional breakpoint.
And let's take a look at
our watch expressions.
So I can still add things
like objects to my watch
expressions and have those been
watched during my workflow.
So pretty much everything works
the same way that you'd
expect it to.
Now if we're saying that you're
getting a slightly
better editing experience inside
the DevTools, one thing
that we commonly need to do is
have access to some sort of
revision history.
Now, you actually get access to
this by right clicking on
any file, going to the Context
menu, and then clicking on
Local Modifications.
What this will do is-- and let's
make some modifications.
Let's say, var test equals
some object.
Let's save that.
And what you can see is that
I get a complete revision
history where I can go and
revert back all the changes
that I've made up to
a certain point.
I can apply a specific change
at a particular
timestamp if I want.
Or I can apply a specific
revision to my original files.
And this is really useful.
So rather than having to just
sort of worry that a change
that I'm making during my live
editing and debugging workflow
is going to come back to bite
me later, I can easily trust
local modifications to
save those changes.
And I can go and I can revert
back to them if needed.
So I'm to go and I'm going
to escape that.
Now, you can actually get some
nice mileage using some of the
other buttons that are at the
bottom of the Sources panel.
So let's take a look
at some of those.
Now, it's quite common when
you're working on an
application of some
sort to have a few
tiles that are minified.
And these may be outside of
your own build process.
So maybe it's like a minified
version of jQuery or Backbone
or something else, and you just
want to make it a little
bit more readable, because the
minified form of this file is
this is just not that
easy to work with.
So using the curly braces button
at the very bottom,
this one that says "pretty
print," I can click on that.
And it'll go and it'll beautify
my JavaScript for me.
So I can go-- and this is a
little bit more easy to read.
It's much more neatly
white spaced out.
It's a lot more easy for me
to go Through And I can
go and I can use--
although some of these variable
names are going to be
minified, I can actually mostly
still use my same
shortcut for displaying all
of these methods to access
things, which is great.
Now, if you're working on a
project which has really any
number of large files on it,
you're going to want to be
able to easily locate things,
whether it be inside a
specific file, or across
your entire project.
Now, there are some useful
keyboard shortcuts which can
help you achieve this, and I'm
going to go through some of
them right now.
So we've already gone through
one of them, which is finding
a method in a specific file.
So for any of the shortcuts I'm
going to go through, I'll
probably be using
the Mac specific
version, which uses Command.
But if you're on Windows or
you're on Linux, you can use
Control instead of Command to
achieve the exact same thing.
So if I want to locate a
specific method inside a file,
I want to filter down to a
specific method-- or in the
case of a style sheet,
a specific property--
I can use Command-Shift-O. And
like earlier, I can filter
down to updatesearch.
I can filter down to pretty
much any method I want.
And by clicking on it, it will
take me to the line number
where that method or function
exists, which is great.
Another thing I might want to
be able to do is open or
filter the list of
files that are
available inside a project.
And I can do that with
Command-O. So this will go and
it will display all the
different files that I have
available to me.
If I'm looking for my style
file, I can start typing.
And as you can see, it's
filtered down the list to
those results that are
relevant to me.
If I'm looking for all of my
JavaScript files, I can just
type in .js and achieve the
exact same thing, which is,
again, quite helpful.
Now, if I want to navigate to
a specific line that I know
exists inside my file, you can
use Command-L to achieve this.
So here, I'm going to go
to line number 56.
And as I can see, I'm in the
region of my updatesearch
method once again, which
is really great.
Now, some of the different
panels inside the DevTools
have their own find feature,
which works at a context level
on the material that
you're working on.
So in the case of the Sources
panel, Command-F will bring up
a nice little search box in
the very bottom, near the
Sources toolbar at the very
bottom of the screen.
And I can start typing
in here to look at
things inside this file.
So I can find my updatesearch
once again using this.
I can find specific variable
names, or pretty much anything
that I want.
And I can use these navigation
toggles to go back and forth
between different
search results.
I can actually also go and find
and replace different
content if I want to, the same
way that I would in a normal
text editor, which
can be useful.
And this type of functionality
is present on a few different
panels, including Network, and
I believe Resources as well.
So if you're using those panels,
you can also use
Command-F on them.
Typically, we also need to be
able to search across all of
the files that form
our project.
And we can do this using another
keyboard shortcut,
which is Command-Option-F.
What this gives me is the
ability to look across every
single file in my project.
So let me look for something
like document.
I want to see what files in this
project on use the word
document in them.
And as you can see, it's giving
me a list of all the
different files, as well as the
line numbers where these
occurrences are.
And I can go and I can
click on any result.
It'll actually open
it up inside the
Source panel editor.
And I can go and I can make
any changes that I want to
those files quite easily.
So you can expend any of these
search results and it'll give
you a preview of where it's
found, the instance of what
you've been looking for.
And this feature also supports
some nice things like regular
expressions, if you
want to use those.
So let's hit escape again
to kill the console.
Now that's great.
I'm able to pretty
much edit files
directly inside the DevTools.
I can load up local projects,
entire projects, so I can see
all the different files.
And if I close Chrome or close
the DevTools, that project, as
long as I want it to be, will
still be around, so I don't
have to go manually opening up
any individual files that I
want to debug or edit.
That's great.
Now, if you'd like to start
using Workspaces today, the
first thing you're going to need
to do is make sure you're
using Google Chrome Canary, so
the Canary release channel.
The next thing you want to do is
go to About Flags, and look
for the Developer Tools
experiments.
So I'm looking for
Developer Tools.
And you just want to make sure
that you enable developer
Tools experiments, and
then relaunch Chrome.
The next thing you want to do
is go to the Settings pane
once you're fired up DevTools.
Go to Experiments, and Enable
File System Folders in Sources
Panel, so this option that
I have open right here.
You then need to relaunch
your Developer Tools.
And you'll get access to a new
feature called Workspace that
appears as a tab.
And you can then go and add as
many different file systems as
you want, and you even have
some configuration options
around the different file
mappings that are also set.
And that's it.
You should be able to work with
projects directly inside
the tools, which can be nice.
Sometimes you want to be able
to save smaller scripts,
utilities, and bookmarklets so
that they're always available
to you inside the DevTools.
There's a new feature
that can help you
with this called snippets.
So to use snippets, go
to the Sources panel.
And in the left hand Nav, find
the snippets sub-bar.
Now in the tree view here, you
can see that I already have
some snippets that I
created earlier.
To create a brand new snippet,
right click inside the Tree
View and hit New.
You can then customize the name
of your snippet to be
pretty much whatever you want.
In my case, I'm going to
call it cornify.js.
You can then paste in the
contents of a bookmarklet, or
write any custom script that you
want to form your snippet.
In my case, I'm going to paste
in my cornify script.
And I can then run this against
any local object if I
want-- the Window, the
Navigator, and so on--
but I'll mostly be using this
against the current page.
Now, there are two ways you
can execute a snippet.
You can either use the
triangular button at the very
bottom of the Sources bar, which
will basically go and
run it, or you can use
the keyboard shortcut
Control-Shift-E, which will
also do the same thing.
So in our case, we're
going to use
Control-Shift-E, run my snippet.
And what you can see is it's
gone and it's added a really,
really awesome rainbow
to my page.
I can go and I can run
this once again.
Boom!
I've got a unicorn.
This page is so much more
functional now.
And that's great.
As you can see, I can actually
go to any script here.
So I can go to CSS Prettifier,
which I'll be
showing you in a moment.
But I can add breakpoints
to this page.
I can treat this as pretty
much any normal script.
I can live edit it.
I can live debug it.
And that's great.
Another nice thing about this
feature is it basically gives
you access to a lovely multiline
console with both
syntax highlighting
and persistence.
So you can basically go and
do anything you want.
And hit to the next line, keep
editing this the same way that
you would any other script,
which is great.
Now, to show you another example
of a bookmarklet, I
created CSS Prettifier.
And I'm currently on a page--
so normally when you're view
sourcing a page, you might be
trying to check out the
JavaScript on that page,
and the CSS.
And when you try going and
looking at the raw version of
that, it's not very easy
to do that always.
Because sometimes those style
sheets might be minified and
those scripts might
be minified too.
So in this case, what I'm
going to do with CSS
Prettifier is I'm just going
to go and I'm going to run
this against the current page.
And as you can see, it's gone
and it's prettified my CSS,
making it much more readable,
much more accessible to me,
which is great.
So snippets have got a
lot of capabilities.
You can use all the same panels
as you would for your
debugging and editing workflows,
as we were looking
at earlier with Workspaces.
And to enable them and start
using snippets today, all you
need to do is go to the settings
cog, go back to
Experiments, and just check
Snippets Support.
Now, at the current time,
snippets are still in
experimental.
We're expecting for them
to sort of come out of
experiments quite soon, so you
may not even need to enable
them in the future, and
that's the hope.
So we've looked at Workspaces.
We've looked at snippets.
The next thing we're going to
look at is an improved Sass
debugging workflow inside
the DevTools.
If you enjoy working with an
abstraction language like
Sass, your workflow inside the
DevTools has probably been a
little bit limited.
The reason is, although you
can edit CSS inside the
sources panel or via the
Elements panel, none of the
changes that you make will
actually go and be propagated
back to your original
Sass source files.
And that means that as soon as
you run the Sass compiler, any
changes made to your CSS from
the DevTools will be
overwritten.
That workflow changes now with
some recent improvements that
we've made.
I'm going to go over to the
Elements panel and inspecting
the top root of the HTML5 Please
page, I'm going to go
and take a look at some
of our styles.
So here I see background
color 232927.
Now I can actually command and
click into this color, and be
taken to the dark variable name,
which expresses what
this color is, which
is fantastic.
Going back to Elements, I can
actually also Command click on
background color, to be taken
to the reference where we're
saying, OK, we'll use the
dark variable for this
color, which is great.
I'm going to go and I'm now
going to inspect the H1 for
this page, so HTML5 Please.
And what you'll notice in this
side, is that rather than us
referring to style.css or just
the CSS, we're actually now
referring to line
numbers for the
original Sass source files.
So I can go, and by clicking on
style.css, it will actually
take me to line source for this
style, which is great.
And I can now go and
start making
actual changes to these.
I have another feature called
on which basically allows me
to reload whenever changes are
makes my Sass files, and I'm
going to preview what that
looks like right now.
So I now want to make
a change to one of
my Sass source files.
There's actually a Sass function
that I defined
earlier called OMG.
And I'd like to change my
text-shadow to use that
instead of what we've
got at the moment.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to go to text-shadow,
type in omg--
let's clean up some
of this stuff--
and I'm just going
to Command-S and
take a look at this.
Boom!
So what that's done is it's
actually gone and compiled my
Sass file into CSS, and it's
being previewed inside of the
Chrome without me having to go
and use any additional tools
separately.
So I do have my Sass compiler
running in the background and
watching everything.
But that's about it.
Now, in order to enable this
Sass editing workflow, you
need to go to DevTools Settings,
go to Experiments,
and first of all, make
sure you have
support for Sass checked.
After that, you'll probably have
to relaunch the tools.
Next, go to General, scroll
down, and you want to Enable
Source Maps, as well
as the Auto-reload
CSS upon Sass Save.
And that's what basically allows
us to reload without
having to go and do anything
extra like
refresh the page manually.
Finally, make sure that you're
running the Sass compile there
was some specific flags
in the background.
In this case we're using Sass,
Watch, SCSS, Sourcemap, and
then defining the input and
output for our files.
And that's it.
If you'd like to stay on top of
the latest news to do with
the Chrome DevTools, please feel
free to follow us on Plus
on the Google Chrome
Developers channel.
On Twitter, you can catch us
on ChromiumDev, or you can
watch our regular show, "The
Breakpoint," which captures
the latest and greatest in
the world of tooling.
Until next time, thank
you, and goodbye.